religion was in the news is big pupil
does a big survey every seven years so
what the Pew the Pew poll I've heard
about you poll it sounds like a fart in
church the Bell you poll you never heard
you
we added whole panels and I do never
reads the news anyway they they do a big
survey of religion every seven years and
the results are in and they're pretty
amazing the number of Christians has
gone down from two thousand seven to
fourteen from seventy eight percent to
seventy percent the number of nuns
that's people who none none of the above
these are atheists agnostics people who
just want to sleep in on Sunday we're
now second sits of Angelica 25% nuns
twenty three percent and mostly this is
because Malena you're shut know what
because it may absolutely
but the Millennials are most at 35
percent of the Millennials are nuns and
they are leaving in droves so they're
trying to get them back they're the key
to stopping this bleeding to the they
have put out this this Bible to try to
get the Millennials back it's it's it's
the King James Franco very it's slightly
different what you like to hear and it's
very similar like here's from the Old
Testament Adam and Eve saw that they
were naked and they were ashamed because
they were not toned so they sewed fig
leaves together together to cover their
problem areas slightly differ you the
Lord's anger burned against Israel and
he made them wander in the wilderness 40
years where they had no signal I see how
this is set that in lineal
and the commandments are slightly
different honor they father and they
mother so that you may live long in
their basement
thou shalt not steal except buying music
online that's all right now let's go to
the New Testament there are also some
some different currents again slightly
different Oh Jesus says take this and
eat of it for it is gluten-free blessed
be thy fruit of thy womb it is locally
grown be Jesus our I remember this one
said to Peter this very night before the
crows you will deny me three times
because the haters gonna hate hate a sow
verily just shake it off and we know not
on what hour thy Lord will return but
the uber will be there informal